Putin is in talks with the Taliban to
buy the weapons the U.S left behind in
Afghanistan when the U.S withdrew from
Afghanistan they left behind seven
billion dollars worth of military
equipment this includes aircraft nearly
10 000 air-to-ground Munitions 40 000
military vehicles weapons explosives
night vision goggles and a ton more the
Taliban can't maintain a lot of this
stuff but you know who can who Putin has
lost a ton of Tanks armored vehicles
Jets and More in Ukraine Putin has been
restocking weapons thanks to North Korea
and now he's allegedly in talks with a
Taliban to do the same which is
hilarious because your tax dollars went
into Afghanistan those same tax dollars
were then transferred to the Taliban and
now those same tax dollars are going to
be transferred to Putin so that he can
continue the war in Ukraine which your
tax dollars are also funding welcome to
America because